one parasitic manipulation and that
perhaps the oldest one known on the
books is what the rabies virus does and
as everyone knows that once you you know
a rabid animal bites you the virus can
then travel to the brain and what it
does is it invades the hypothalamus
which is the center of the brain that
controls all our most fundamental drives
for example you know anger and
aggression hunger and your sex drive and
it's not commonly known but a a typical
symptom of rabies is hyper sexuality and
people who become infected it can
occasionally just develop this voracious
appetite for sex and there are a number
of scientists who think that the vampire
legend actually is based on rabies that
it's it's rabies that was the
inspiration for it because as we know
for example vampires are hyper sexual
another aspect of rabies and people is
that it makes people very sensitive to
any kind of stimuli for so for example
even the lightest breeze can make
somebody agitated and people with rabies
also they hate strong light it really
bothers them and they for reasons no one
understands they become hydrophobic
which is to say they are tormented by
the sight of water or hearing you know
water splashing in a basin and if you
think about vampire legend well vampires
hate light that's why they're nocturnal
and in the 18th century when a lot of
vampire legends swept Eastern Europe
was thought that pouring water around
the grave of a person would keep them
from rising at night and becoming a
vampire also in Eastern Europe at that
time it was believed and these weren't
just legends they believed that this was
a true risk it was thought that some
people could rise from their beds at
night and then assume the form of a dog
or wolf and attack people or rape people
so you can see how vampire legend has
you know vampirism maybe in some ways
inspired by what rabies does to people
and of course vampires are most likely
to assume the form of dogs which we know
are it can be you know one vector of
rabies but also bats which can spread
rabies and then finally this is an
interesting link it typically takes
about 40 days from the time a person is
bitten by a rabid animal until their
death and vampires
according to legend lived 40 days